hey everybody welcome to movie threesome
our guest today from Shadowhunters
Isaiah Mustafa is here thank you so much
bonus today is your birthday so I you
some good cupcakes and yeah you got to
go to the Super Bowl in my team won
that's the best part about it learning
the fact that you were Broncos fan and
going my buddy played played quarterback
for the Broncos back in like I think
retired in 2007-2008 Jake Plummer the
only man to ever beat Tom Brady three
times two times in the playoff that's a
good friend but I went with him and I
always uh I always go to super bowl with
him and we just kind of have a good time
he was my college quarterback so you
took your love for sports and you have a
hockey show that you knew as well too I
do i do I love this wild game of hockey
so i created this the show with the help
of todd Roy and Eddie Eddie Bernard and
we called the seven-minute hockey show
what's a typical show you know what you
guys do here yeah throw hockey in them
okay everyone back yeah donnalyn fair
here hey boy it's not water balloons
it's beer oh yeah I'm not sure and he
does beer balloon bongs and and then he
plays the drums at the same time while I
sit on the couch we interview a guest
you have a pretty cool relationship with
sports and football in general because
the whole Old Spice viral campaign also
started during the Super Bowl actually I
can't say that because the commercial
never aired on the Super Bowl that's
that's the biggest misnomer about it it
actually aired before super bowl and
after a game on YouTube oh really yeah
that was the that that's why advertising
companies now that's why they show you
the commercial before the Super Bowl is
because they found out what happened
when the wind Old Spice stumbled upon
this formula let's talk about shout
honors I want to talk about as far as
fantasy the supernatural like is that
something was out of genre that you're
just interested in general but even
before being on the show and I love
sci-fi fantasy and I've always wanted to
play some sort of superhero or something
like that so I never thought I'd be Luke
Garroway I'm not playing Luke Garroway
on Shadowhunters but it's fun I like
doing it going back to what you said as
far as being a fan of the supernatural
movies and and fantasy what are you some
of the favorite was that you've seen I'd
say in the last two years I like days of
future past I mean I I'm a big x-men fan
so I dive in there's a couple things I
didn't like but um
you know I'm a purist you know so yeah
when you read comic books so much you
really wanted to follow but then you
think about it like I couldn't do it any
better you know so so I should shut my
mouth and it just enjoy the product
that's put in front of me right so how
did you feel about the x-men apocalypse
trailer that was during the Super Bowl I
was at the super bright yellow wash you
don't mind yeah Oh interesting you'll
see it was great though lucky for you
there's a playlist on movie scripts it
has all that stuff and we look at it
Segway we talk Thank You Tiffany of
myself the whole breakdown of all the
trailers all the TV spots and bonus
little tidbit just lost Oscar Isaac in
ex machina in the apocalypse yes and
also in the force awakens so apparently
that guy is the one you go to that also
in the slums of Beverly Hills is that
true wasn't he in that movie won't you
got it right you should yell at
everybody for doubt I wouldn't yell at
anyone like shame you know i would i
might put you in the penalty box come
over my house is it like that sounded
kind of inappropriate the pillar-box
hockey show there's a penalty box read
if you come over I'll put you in the
penalty box well because there's an ice
rink in my garage hockey we were not at
the Super Bowl no but we did get to make
some wagers we we won't we didn't do it
last week we tried to get back from
Sundance and she got us lost I did not
get him watch that footage you guys
drive you said go right no I said left I
said right when you said left this is
great i should be home laying by a pool
relax now i gotta poop all right you see
clearly it was Tiffany's fall from that
clip it was your fault I will go first
and we will bet on Deadpool and i will
say Deadpool is going to make 60 1.5
million opening weekend I am gonna say
that Deadpool is going to make 56
million opening weekend I think that's a
safe bet it's got like a ninety-nine
percent on rotten tomatoes make sure you
put the hashtag loser shoulds in the
comments below and on twitter and on
facebook please something terrible will
happen to christian next week because
i'm gonna win art speaking of Deadpool
it is time for today's topics
all right all about Deadpool and the
wager now I have question for both you
guys both comic book movie fans it's
rated R we know that's kind of one of
the reasons that you want a little lower
in your prediction so the question I say
that I have to use do you think that
this Deadpool needed to be rated R could
it have succeeded as a pg-13 know well I
just think he's crazy I mean anytime you
have a crazy person you want to explore
all the you know facets of their
personality and I think our an r-rated
movie kinda allows you to go places that
you wouldn't normally go for like with
pg-13 could they have made a pg-13 movie
sure would it have been as good as what
they made a later are no way I've ever
seeing it I can say that because you've
seen it yes I had every both both have
it it is it it's why I see the Super
Bowl you look horrible movie a good way
now you're the soldier super bowl
everybody who is here loves you were the
only girls go for God's sake everybody
in here saw what happened we don't know
what happened but you can see it on your
ID there's always have to ryan reynolds
so finally gets to portray deadpool the
way that he wanted to he's played green
lantern before even Ryan's himself knows
it is a little bit of negative I kind of
liked him in Greenland he did I did I'm
not gonna lie to you I think this is the
one that people are gonna really
remember him from for it as I just get
mad every time you like said cuz you say
it with this like thing of like I've
seen it you know I mean like huh he does
for all of that and like go cuz we saw
it yeah we've seen the movie it was
really good you should check it out um
so fans will love it when they get to
see it and oh and there's tons of easter
eggs in the movie that we saw right if
you're an extra thing you're really
gonna love it because it's a break that
Lisa and you didn't well something that
you can do that we haven't done yet is
play a little game Oh for it get revenge
Wow okay let's do that I'd love to do
this
game time and the game that we want to
play today has a superhero theme but it
is called bass ackwards okay it's going
to be different words that are the
opposite of the actual title so for
example nurse normal and the actual
title is dr. strange yes okay so are you
guys ready for this ready so the first
one is lieutenant Canada the summer
peace Captain America winter soldier
nice good that was pretty crazy okay
bird woman never Batman are you and Ryan
geriatric normal pacifist rabbits what's
the Teenage Mutant Ninja turn yes
Christian got a nice fella I'm our
rabbits and turtles are yeah I don't
know how that works another good huh The
Tortoise and the hare yeah yeah oh maybe
the opposite of a turtle well there is
no opposite of a turtle yeah a hair
heaven girl hell boy that is correct
living pond living pond are you serious
yeah living pond what's the opposite of
living dying Dead Pool there you go
bondan pool yeah i got like oh man on
the pool it's the same freaking thing
it's different but not this app this
game why don't you just let Isaiah have
this wind stopping us we use on the same
point with night I am on his side on
this one so hey i forfeit my win just to
join your team thank you
I just a huge thank you guys and for
joining us on the show had a good time
oh honey I'm sweating like I'm Eminem
innocent little don't worry about it cuz
now it's time to end the show watch even
while you're here make sure you
subscribe to our channel click boom
right over there like right there and
watch past episodes right here well and
download the fandango movie clips app on
your smartphone and catch us next week
on mommy